faut-il se marier
il joue beaucoup d'enfants de l'île vote
avec sur le gaz - tabac à l'alcool
immense al khaimah
voilà sorti le 25 août et on sent
vraiment en voyant ce film que vous êtes
un fou de cinéma ya bonheur de filmer il
ya une jubilation à filmer il ya des
moments si vous éclater il ya un côté
lellouche dans le plaisir qu'il avait à
filmer il ya 30 ans quand on sent que ça
vous plaît quoi sa barge aimer le cinéma
vraiment c'est pour ça que aussi j'ai eu
envie de passer derrière après 10 ans en
devant ça que j'aime ça et que si je
pouvais même aller sur un film et faire
juste le casting si je pourrais je sais
pas quoi ce sens les passionnés de
cinéma en ce sens vous avez un fou de
cinéma vraiment il ya une scène où ils
sont avec chabat et alain cohen tous les
trois ou chabat ne pas remonter chez lui
parce qu emmanuelle seigner lukas
vraiment les couilles et il aimerait que
ses copains reste avec lui et les autres
veulent se barrer parce qu'ils en ont
ras le bol et ses magnifiques oissel
n'en finit plus et dans le hall d'un
immeuble un peu un peu comme ce à quoi
les trois mecs vendent des bagnoles
enfin c'est pas ils vendent les bagnoles
ils vivent leur vie chacun avec leur
femme leurs enfants et est tous en ont
un peu reculé 2 les deux mariés en vie
la vie du célibataire le célibataire
envie david et marié bien que lui-même
se fait un peu chier dans la vie la
solitude c'est presque pire que tout
levesque coucher tout seul et on suit
ces trois mecs pendant un long moment
avant de bifurquer au détour d'une allée
chez virgin quand charlotte c'est
terrible c'est plutôt une belle c'est
n'y a aucun mot qui énerve tout les deux
écoutes le même disque un rond-point
j'imagine comme on peut écouter de la
musique et puis tous les deux écoutes le
même disque puis se passe des choses
entre eux sans qu'ils aient besoin de
dire quoi que ce soit ce qui est très
bien aussi dans votre signe qu'il ya des
séquences oniriques comme ça on sait pas
si c'est des des flashforwards 6 et des
séquences imaginaire enfin il ya un peu
de tout mais si ça c'est une séquence
réel d'ailleurs elle rentre à la maison
elle a acheté le disque i et puis
elle fait la cuisine à l'ecoute ce
disque on sent bien qu'elle ait calé
ailleurs il ya d'autres séquences qui
sont imaginaires et un moment et les
agents immobiliers charlotte elle fait
visiter un appartement puis tout d'un
coup ou deux comme ça au milieu de la
visite
elle se rend compte en faisant visiter
l'appartement de ce que pourrait être la
vie des autres est ce que pourrait être
sa vie et elle s'imagine la vie sans lui
à ce moment là vraiment il part avec
elle dans son imaginaire elle s'imagine
la vie sans son mari se rend compte que
sa ville bien il lui dit les enfants
c'est toi qui les pousse à une scène
totalement imaginaire mélange de ces
nouvelles de scène imaginaire c'est
assez c'est assez bien foutu bon d'être
doué merci beaucoup
vraiment vous avez une bonne pression je
pourrais vous les faits un peu dans
votre coin en vous disant bon c'est plus
difficile de faire un deuxième film
parce que le premier on n'a absolument
rien à perdre
et puis quand le premier à marcher alors
on espère que le deuxième
vous donnera la possibilité de faire le
troisième enfin est inquiet la france le
24 août maintenant on est inquiet tout
l'été et ceci dit je vais tourner un
film pour me ça a bien marché le le
premier là ma femme est une actrice bien
très bien car les mecs été fait non il a
ri mais qui n'a pas été fait et
heureusement parce que c'est
probablement steven spielberg qui va le
faire oh voilà c'est un jeune vétéran
j'ai eu l'occasion de le rencontrer à
paris pour son prochain film
et puis quand il m'a demandé ce que je
voulais lui montrer pour qu'ils me
voient acteur je lui ai donné un dvd de
mon film et puis
il l'a vu j'ai été très étonné qu'ils le
voient le soir même il m'a rappelé le
soir même pour me dire qu'il avait adoré
qu'il m'a demandé si les droits de
remake qui était pris voilà donc je
pense que en bas au mas à ronger ses
biens dans un